je crois que c'est une très belle robe à
qui bah Fatou une très belle robe
d'anniversaire et des belles chaussures
aussi j'adore lui offrir des chaussures
en fait des escarpins on va dans les
boutiques et on arpente on choisit
ensemble les essais devant moi j'adore
et dès qu'elle essaie j'achète ah ouais
ah bah oui c'est tellement beau sur elle
que voilà elle porte divinement les
escarpins avec un mot légal B comme ça
et tout ça j'adore ça bon les gars c'est
Castaldi
malheureux quoi
c'est incroyable c'est surtout le plus
gros jonc que la terre
c'est un canard WC un truc de ouf c'est
coin coin mais à tous les étages
[Musique]
il faut pas trop
sachez-le n'offrez pas trop de cadeaux
ça fait le mec qui a des choses à se
reprocher
les bonnes questions
non mais je te le dis ça touche Cyril ça
va pas
que des cadeaux c'est quoi toi
j'aime bien weekend à Londres
exceptionnellement
à mon ex qu'elle ne m'a jamais rendu
non la voiture c'est normal mais la
bague de chance
tu rends pas les cadeaux
avec la voiture elle est partie avec
mais après je vais récupérer
au bout de sa vie hein
j'ai acheté une bague super cher et elle
me l'a jamais rendu ah bah non mais ça
c'est normal
bague de fiançailles la voiture tu l'as
récupéré
la voiture ça a été compliqué
ramène-moi la voiture tu l'aurais laissé
grise à mon nom
c'est pas un cadeau
attention mais non c'est un cadeau en
sursis
la meuf ça va lui coûter de l'oseille
c'est vrai je vous jure que c'est vrai
tu vas pas prendre l'assurance et tout
c'est une Fanny il faut que la personne
se prenne quand même un petit peu en
charge
[Rires]
tu peux pas lui mâcher tout le travail
sans déconner voilà je vous dis la
vérité
en voiture sans la carte grise
se débrouiller de rien t'occupe pas du
contrôle technique t'occupes de rien tu
démarres et tu feras tu fais pas
l'évidence alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'appelle pas je suis pas garagiste
parce que moi alors je parle à Daniel ah
d'accord
t'es pas check qui n'est pas seul tu
n'es pas seul
parce que c'est quoi super longtemps
donc faire une très belle robe voilà on
peut voir à la télé parce que j'avais
mis ma robe pour quand j'avais fait
aujourd'hui madame la télé
non pas de non
bijoux pas de fleurs c'est pas bijoux
même pas une couronne mortuaire
une fois par semaine
c'est bon bon les fleurs hein
c'est bon bon les fleurs il a raison
Nikos
elle est magnifique
ok bon bah très bien
écoutez l'anecdote de Raymond
très envie
alors attention j'ai 17 ans et demi je
suis cariste je touche 5115 francs je
vais rue Saint-Denis à Colombes dans le
centre dans le centre 5115 francs pas
mal 700 € attention c'est c'est 11500
bleu de travail je vais à la bijouterie
la grande bijouterie de la rue
Saint-Denis c'est la rue commerçante à
Colombes tout le monde connaît je
voudrais la base vous avez quoi comme
bague on a ça oui des bagues 7000 francs
8000 francs je suis là je passe pas on a
ça mais vous avez pas moins flashy on a
ça à 3200 francs 3200 francs sur 5000
francs de
jamais dans ma poche je vais voir Elsa à
18e étage si tu es d'Orgemont j'arrive à
18e
petite blonde elle est à la fac tout le
monde voulait sortir la caisse comme
elle étudier elle va être intelligente
[Rires]
elle ouvre la porte et je vois elle est
triste je la bague c'est pas pour tout
de suite c'est pas il y a pas il y a pas
une grosse ambiance je vais dans la
chambre et tout elle me dit ce qu'on va
se discuter j'ai toujours là-bas devant
nous et je dis qu'est-ce qu'il y a un
problème et tout à fait oui c'est fini
on arrête ah merde c'est vrai je suis
quand même 3200 balles
et j'ai fait l'histoire genre beau gosse
j'écoute si tu veux arrêter arrête ça à
la base c'était pour toi donc je te
l'offre
[Applaudissements]
c'était tous les noms
mais c'est fini pourquoi ça arrive mais
c'est ça
j'ai pleuré dans l'ascenseur
3200 francs
5000 francs de salaire tu me dis sérieux
mais peut-être qu'elle a gardé peut-être
et qu'elle garde encore hein
j'espère en disant cet homme-là était
extrêmement
[Applaudissements]